[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers from all
different disciplines my guest today is
Shirley a sarman PT PhD but before we
get to her bio let me just explain
Shirley is a legend in the physical
therapy world she has influenced some of
the top performance coaches in the world
she's also 85 years old going on 86 and
is not only razor sharp mentally but in
excellent shape physically so she walks
the walk so let me get to the bio and
I'll also give you a bit of 101 on some
of the terms that we'll use in the
conversation
Shirley a sarman PT PhD is Professor
emerita of physical therapy at
Washington University School of Medicine
in St Louis Missouri she received her
bachelor's degree in physical therapy
and her Master's in Doctorate Degrees in
neurobiology from Washington University
where she joined the physical therapy
faculty and became the first director of
their PHD program in movement science
Shirley and she asked me to call her
Shirley became a Catherine Worthington
fellow of the American Physical Therapy
Association in 1986 and in 1998 was
selected to receive the Mary MacMillan
award the association's highest honor
she has also received Washington
University's distinguished faculty award
the distinguished alumni award the
school of medicine's inaugural
distinguished clinician award and an
honorary doctorate from the University
of Indianapolis she has received as well
the bowling erdheart Orthopedic clinical
practice award from the orthopedic
Academy of the APTA she has served on
the APTA board of directors and as
president of the Missouri chapter her
book books are iconic they have been the
initial Domino that has toppled over so
to speak the enthusiasm the ignition for
many people to get into the field of
movement science and physical therapy
and performance coaching her first book
diagnosis and treatment of movement
impairment syndromes you may have heard
Eric Cressy mentioned this it was a
hugely influential book for him has been
translated into seven languages her
second book movement system impairment
syndromes of the cervical and thoracic
spines and the extremities has been
equally influential in promoting
movement diagnoses and in this episode
we do a deep dive on low back pain and
that is something that for the first
time really I have been struggling with
for the last let's just call it nine
months or so could be a bit longer
and we do get into the weeds with regard
to Anatomy particularly as it relates to
the back stuff that I mentioned so I'd
like to go over a few terms before we
start the interview so you don't have to
wonder what they are and feel like you
need to pause to look them up you can
get through the interview without
listening to my definitions but some of
them might be helpful also if you're a
kinesiologist a professional please
excuse these very simplistic and
possibly slightly off definitions but
they'll help a lot of people so the
first one is the iliac crest what is
that that's the uppermost border of your
pelvic girdle so you can think of the
pelvic girdle as that large bony ball
that you see in the middle of a skeleton
hanging in a science classroom or
something you can feel your iliac crest
if you press your thumb into the top of
your hip that sort of bony Ridge is your
iliac crest the tensor fascia latte and
I've heard many different pronunciations
of this and the fact of the matter is no
one really speaks Latin correctly
because we don't know if it was you know
veiny vedi Vichy
for those who get that reference I came
I saw I conquered so anyway it is better
known and abbreviated as the tfl for a
lot of people so the tfl is a muscle at
the outside very outside portion of the
thigh at the very top so you could think
of it also people think of it as a hip
muscle sometimes you use it to balance
your pelvis when standing walking or
running if you ever give someone a
piggyback ride and a muscle gets super
sore on the side of your hip that is
probably at least including the tfl you
also use the tfl for abducting your hip
or pulling it away from the midline of
your body compared to adducting with 2DS
which would be playing it toward the
midline one way that I remember that
abduction it's like an alien abduction
taking you away so moving the say leg
away from body abducting bringing the
thigh in adduction so like an adductor
machine at a gym one of those Susan
Summers Thigh Master type machines would
be that we also talk about muscles that
assist in lateral rotation lateral
rotation is rotating away from the
center of the body medial rotation is
rotating towards the center so imagine
if you turned your feet outwards to look
like you were duck footed that would be
lateral rotation out to the sides and
then if you turn them inward to be
pigeon toed that would be medial
rotation of both femurs inward all right
so as major I also mentioned psoas major
that's spelled p-s-o-a-s major that is a
large muscle that joins the upper and
lower parts of the body and it also
contributes to a lot of lower back pain
it connects to the inside of the lower
back and if you were to take say your
four fingers and move them four inches
to either side of your navel and then
press in say four inches that would
probably touch your soas major which is
why massage therapy that addresses it
can be so uncomfortable for you Chef
cell out there or hunters or people who
might recognize this this would be the
equivalent of your tenderloin so if
you're wondering what a tenderloin is it
is this muscle in many animals and there
may be other ways to use that butchering
term but so as major tenderloin there
you have it used mostly for posture and
so on
we also get into stenosis as it relates
to my spine so stenosis is an abnormal
narrowing and I have some stenosis
around L4 L5 which is in the lumbar
spine or lower spine which puts pressure
on some nerves there and causes all
sorts of pain the thoracic spine is more
of say the middle of the back and kind
of you just think between the shoulder
blades for Simplicity okay last and
I could say not least but who knows
these are all kind of equivalent and
useful you have supine versus prone
positions supine is lying on your back
prone is lying on your stomach if you've
ever wondered what a supinated grip is
or a pronated grip supinated is Paul up
and you can remember that because if you
want to pour soup into your hand you
have your palm up okay so that is Supine
and honestly learning the basics of
anatomy and the basics of some medical
terminology is I think one of the best
absolute the best investments you can
make in your health because then you can
talk the talk with professionals and
they take you more seriously they give
you better advice they give you the
straight scoop so this is all a very
good investment of time you can find a
glossary of these terms and more in the
show notes for this episode of tim.blog
and I do want to mention one other thing
if you want an incredible rotating view
of different muscles like the ql we talk
about the quadratus lumborum that's sort
of this squarish rectangular muscle in
the lower back area that is sort of the
Grand Central Station of all sorts of
things
do you want to see anything the soas
major check out the essential Anatomy 5
app for IOS and Android
and you can see all of this you can also
see the circulatory system and all sorts
of other things it's a great app really
enjoyed it and there are short YouTube
tutorials that I recommend taking a look
at if you end up downloading it and that
was referred to me by professional
drummer Dave elich who helps people
improve their mechanics technique and
much more and there you have it so if
you want a video to go with this I did
record a video of this conversation and
I get up and walk around and she does an
assessment with me live you can go to my
YouTube channel youtube.com Tim
ferris2rs2s's and that will have some
helpful graphics and so on overlaid into
the video okay that's quite a bit guys
but I think it is a helpful Prelude and
now without further Ado please enjoy
this wide ranging conversation with Dr
Shirley sarman Dr sarman Shirley welcome
to the show it's so nice to have you
with me today and I can't wait to ask
a whole host of different questions so
thank you for making the time
my pleasure I'd like to begin perhaps
with the connective tissue that led to
you being on the show today which is a
friend of mine and a well-known
I suppose the Label Performance coach
could be applied he also has a
background of physical therapy Eric
Cressy he works with many major league
baseball players has a high degree of
success with pitchers specifically but
he has written and he also mentioned to
me that
diagnosis and treatment of movement
impairment syndromes is probably the
book and I'm quoting him here it's
probably the book that has influenced me
more than any other in my career it's
worth every penny I'm curious why it is
that this book
seems to have been so revolutionary for
him and many others what would you say
explains that or differentiates that
book
I think the one big objective in it I've
actually been a physical therapist for
over 60 years and
during all of that time I've been
through different eras of changes in
physical therapy
and where I've sort of gotten to and
is how movement basically induces
pathology
and part of trying to explain that and
how it works is also developing
diagnostic categories that direct
Physical Therapy treatment
so what this this book was about was a
first attempt to really put together
diagnostic categories that are based on
on movement and movement as an inducer
of musculoskeletal problems
and also kind of working on the on the
background of what are the tissue
adaptations that contribute to this so
it really was an organizational attempt
to identify
in the first book we covered the back
and the shoulder and the hip and so I
guess the shoulder is one of the things
that he must have been particularly
interested in if he's dealing with
pictures
and the shoulder is really quite complex
because you've got that shoulder blade
as well as the glenohumeral joint
and it's not as easy as muscles just
turn on or turn off appropriately
they've got to really be well
coordinated so I think
that putting together this kind of
information in a way that
could be understood by a whole variety
of people in fact I was so slow in
getting it out that I was grateful that
there was the internet and Amazon
selling things because if it would have
only been sold in medical bookstores no
one like Eric would have ever found it
and so that was one of the advantages of
being a slow rider and of course I'd
learn more while all that was happening
too
so that's probably the background how
did that attempt or maybe not attempt
how did that organization is an approach
yeah and also the maybe reframing of
movement in the way that you just
described differ from what came before
or what was predominant at the time well
to be perfectly honest with you Tim
it's not like
this insight has been taken over by even
the large majority of the people in my
profession
it's still still a bit of a struggle to
have people move in this direction for a
whole variety of reasons
but typically in even though I wasn't
there when Physical Therapy was first
started I wasn't too far behind
typically the role of the of the
physical therapist was the doctor
figured out what the problem was made
the diagnosis and the physical therapist
really provided
treatment fruit
what I think could fairly be called the
symptoms or the consequences of that
problem in fact I I am old enough that I
actually saw polio patients the vaccine
had just come out about when I was
entering physical therapy school so
we had a role in
providing the therapy for the doctors
identified condition and that's very
different than what I'm proposing or
have proposed with this book and I think
what's beginning to be recognized
I think the other thing that that's so
important about all this and
I'm sure you are a reflection of this is
in the old days no one thought lifestyle
had anything to do with your health
yeah I always like to point out the
story my family cooked with so much
Crisco I don't know how my blood flows
you know and if the green beans were too
healthy we had bacon grease to put on
them you know
but I I was I was very fortunate I
worked with a physician for a while who
who was really leading the way and
showing about the role of exercise and
nutrition
and he did what this really called
translational research showing the the
cellular changes in animals and then
also running studies in older people and
it was like an amazing insight for me to
realize that your lifestyle had
something to do with it so I think
that's behind what's slowly emerging and
seeing movement play a different role
it's I think what I'm like to get across
to people it's not inevitable
what's gonna happen to you that you can
do things
by a lifestyle to improve what your
outcome is going to be
I would love to come back to I believe
and I don't want to misquote you but
something you said which is the
treatment of symptoms so many offices
are treating symptoms perhaps not root
causes and I have I have read
and you can't believe everything you
read on the internet so please correct
me if you get this wrong but that you've
had a new saying that you've described
low back pain as not a diagnosis but a
symptom and could you just speak to that
because I as someone who currently for
the last maybe six to nine months has
had a very perplexing
constellation of symptoms that I
describe as low back pain this I think
will resonate with many people who are
listening so would you mind elaborating
on low back pain as a symptom and not a
diagnosis well I mean just what you're
saying you're saying low back pain
you're just telling me that you've got
pain and you're telling me where you've
got pain that is clearly a symptom
I am from Long Island so sometimes
silliest of questions but gotta start
with the basics well the nice part is
you can actually actually reimbursed for
making that big clever diagnosis so even
without an MD degree
so where where I would be looking at
that problem and I have an idea of what
your problem is wow okay already well
just because like we can talk about that
okay yeah we will I mean I don't want to
sound too a little bit about it but
and so what I would be doing is naming
your low back pain by the movement that
most consistently causes your symptoms
and by changing that movement
reduces our eliminates your symptoms
and so then I'm talking to you about
April cause of the problem now it's not
going down to the tissue level and
saying well you know it's a disc or a
facet Joiner any of the rest of it but
here again in some ways
when you have a problem like that you
can't say in the back but one tissue is
at fault because a lot of tissues have
to change if you're having pain coming
from your back region so
the expertise of a physical therapist
needs to be what is the movement that's
either causing or exacerbating
that problem so I'm curious well maybe
we can we can dive into you said that
you thought you might know what my my
issue is that's because I know you're a
big exerciser yes indeed I mean do you
want me to just give you a ballpark idea
I do absolutely okay well because would
you believe that abdominals can get to
be too much
uh over developed you know it makes some
intuitive sense but it's not something
you hear many people talk about I know
the community of physical therapists
people are really exercising big time I
mean
high intensity exercise is super popular
I'm all for it because it'll increase
our patient load
one of the things that happens when your
abdominals are over developed because
what happens when muscles hypertrophy
they they become stiffer and muscles are
like Springs
so they have a I mean I'm using the
mechanical word of stiffness and so when
the abdominals get to be too much they
increase the compression on your spine
and so the way you can check me out on
this is if you look to see if you take a
deep breath if you go from Maximum
exhalation to maximum inhalation
you should be able to change the
circumference of your rib cage about two
and a half to three inches
and if you can't really do that then it
means that the stiffness of your
abdominal muscles is so much it's adding
to the compression
and then if you have any kind of
asymmetry if for example if you put your
hands on your iliac crest and one iliac
crest is slightly higher than the other
then you're basically your your spine is
in a side Bend and if it's in a side
Bend and you're squeezing on your
vertebrae they're not happy because they
aren't lined up as optimally as possible
do you see what I mean I do absolutely
that's the ballpark idea and that that
also reflects
how we're looking at these problems what
is it about the way you move what is it
about the way
you've exercised or done things that
cause the symptoms
and I would love to spend more time on
this selfishly of course because the
reason I am sitting and not standing for
this interview is because of this this
lower back pain which is so actually
it's worse when you're standing than
when you're sitting it is
worse when I am standing now I do have I
guess what we can jump right into the
weeds
I have a transitional segment if I'm
using the right terminology in my in my
lumbar so I do have quite a bit of
excessive lower back sway or atypical
lower back sway just for people when you
say sway do you mean an increase curve
increase curve yeah like lordosis and
kind of guts hanging out and with that
anterior pelvic tilt right
standing in slow walking say walking
through a museum tend to aggravate it
the most my brother has the same thing
although in the last six months or so
when I sit on a very hard surface like a
hard bench or something like that
it also causes this pain I have had
Imaging but we could maybe we could talk
about Imaging how you see some people
who look like they've gone through a
Mulcher on their back MRI but they're
asymptomatic and then you're right
that's the whole point yeah then you
have the opposite so I do have some
stenosis around like L4 L5 but
the pain feels to me localized around
the SI joint
the relief if this is helpful I know
we're getting a little technical for
some folks but the the relief that I've
had in the last week was actually from
seeing a chiropractor there's a high
degree of variability with chiropractors
but he works with a lot of athletes and
he put me on a machine that that
provided some attraction exactly and he
said I think it's actually that you may
have a disc
pressing on a nerve that runs past the
SI joint so you're misattributing
the cause to the SI and I've had quite a
bit of relief but to answer your
question standing yeah slow walking
combined with standing like going
through a museum or a cocktail party
sitting on Hard surfaces those are the
three things that hurt brisk walking
does not hurt and actually that type of
and this is a primitive interpretation
but sort of repeated stretching of the
hip flexors if I'm getting enough
terminal hip extension feels really good
to the back yeah
so those are a few of the things have
you put your hands on your pelvis to see
when you're walking if it rotates
I have not I would love to know how to
do that properly well I mean
it's not rocket science you know where
your pelvis is you know where your hands
are yeah just because very often when
your hip flexors are not even just not
short just stiff stiffer than your back
as you walk it rotates your pelvis and
that's where you're going to be getting
your symptoms from and evidently when
you go fast enough you're not staying
static and you're causing enough equal
movement but that would be the big thing
when you stand up and you're in this
anterior tilt can you contract your
abdominals enough to get out of the Tilt
I can yeah and then does that decrease
your symptoms it does decrease by
symptoms so if my back is bothering me
I'll very often do basically a forward
fold or a full Squat and then round my
back and get into that flexed position
yeah I I have the the flexed position
and even mild extension does not bother
the back if I do a compression test like
a heel drop test or I pull myself into a
chair it's it's standing straight up
and with compression that shows that
that type of intolerance then I get that
pain kind of directly on the lower spine
the other thing to try Tim is when you
stand up
put your feet apart
separate them out and see if that
changes your symptoms
and what is that doing number one is
this little thing I referred to before
if one iliac crest is higher than
another and it's a test for what we call
relative stiffness so if if you are one
of the big hip flexor that's problematic
is called the tensor fasciae yes
iliotibial band
and it's an abductor so if you put your
feet apart so your hips are abducted it
takes the stretch off of that band and
any kind of asymmetry that you would
have particularly with a transition
vertebrae would be playing into the
symptoms do you see what I mean I do and
then if you put them together and your
symptoms increase
then you would know that that's what's
playing a role in doing this so I'll add
a few more things just because this is a
rare opportunity to get to talk with you
about this so my tfl is very tends to be
very tight and sensitive that's what I
yeah the piriform is also very tight a
piece of this that may or may not be
helpful but what gives my back also some
release is working on the very
specifically the iliacus and then some
of the adductors so on the inside of the
thigh tell me what that means well
having someone really dig
into the abdomen to have me say Okay
extend the leg almost not you working on
somebody else's no it's somebody else
working on it and then it's not very
pleasant for people who are listening
and then
some of my adductors I don't know if
it's Magnus longus or whatever but also
very tight and seemingly potentially
weak but to come back to the the height
maybe the asymmetry of of the iliac
crest my right side seems to get hiked
up a lot and doing wall sits
to try to press them maybe back into
some symmetry seems to alleviate some of
the symptoms as well I don't know if any
of this makes any sense see you just
confirmed one of my thoughts is that if
your right iliac crest is higher than
your left but then I would also bet that
you're right tfl is stiffer than your
left so if that's playing a role then
when you put your feet apart your your
iliac crest should level out and that
should help with your symptoms so
historically when I've been recording
podcasts I basically end up in that
really wide stance
I mean that's useful for maybe
temporarily relieving the symptoms if
I'm recording a podcast in terms of
corrective measures have you ever tried
anything where you're in in the
quadruped position I have actually a
long time ago I did a lot of movement in
quadruped position but I would be
curious to hear what you have in mind
well because part of what happens when
one iliac crest stays higher than
another and I'm not
to be perfectly honest with you I
haven't quite figured it all out yet but
there's some adaptation of the other
hip muscles and I've just found that if
you do this in quadruped you just rock
back
often it will improve the asymmetry huh
so basically being on hands and knees
hands and knees right in and let your
hips drop to about 90 degrees you don't
have to go back all the way you just
need to go back a little bit and go back
by easily pushing with your hands
because otherwise if you activate your
hip flexors
it could pull it contribute to your
problems right and then and then can you
tolerate prone yeah I can tolerate prone
and then you need to just do like just
flex your knee
and then you need to laterally rotate
your hips so you're letting your your
knee Flex to 90 degrees and then let
your foot go in towards the other leg
that's lateral rotation yep and that
kind of motion will help to elongate the
the tfl ITB interesting and you're doing
that leg by leg oh yeah yeah one leg at
a time one leg at a time okay yeah and
you do everything by bilaterally yeah
okay very interesting so you can try
those things let me I will I will do
both of the so let's if we zoom out just
for a moment and thank you for that by
the way we may come back to it how would
you describe the movement systems
syndromes approach so the MSS approach
what would the sort of lay description
of that be
in 2013 the American Physical Therapy
Association adopted the movement system
as its identity and and to me what's
really important about all of this is
then it's a way of trying to say to the
public that there is a body system
called movement the movement system and
it's not like the traditional
anatomically defined systems like the
cardiovascular system or the muscular
musculoskeletal system or the nervous
system it's a system of systems but
that's just like in my mind the immune
system which nothing is more important
in medicine these days than the immune
system and it's a system of system it
uses many of the different organs
in its functions metabolic system is the
same way when you think of it as running
from subcellular all the way up to how
do you move in your environment movement
is is critical but movement stops
everything stops and so I think we take
it in some ways to me it's like a
parallel to the nutrition system
because we take for granted
doing it and yet there's right ways in
the wrong ways and so the whole idea of
this is to realize that their movement
does involve a system
and just like we were talking about
before
movement if you have a lesion in a
system like you have rheumatoid
arthritis or something or you have a
stroke
then you've got pathology in your
movement
but as I indicated movement can also
induce pathology in fact we know if
people don't move enough they develop
the metabolic system and syndrome and
other other kinds of things because for
lack of movement
so
how important it is to move this is
related to The Lifestyle issue and doing
it right
one of the things I always love doing
with patients was saying so who taught
you to walk and they say nobody and I
say that's the problem just because
you're doing it doesn't mean you're
doing it right you're just doing it
just like you if you're walking and
you're getting lumbo pelvic rotation
that's playing into your problem right
and also if I'm if I don't have which I
don't think I do this is a one pattern
of diagnosis with me that I think is
accurate that I'm I don't have much
terminal hip extensions when I walk I'm
using my lower back too that's what I'm
telling you it's an extension see that's
what I'm saying you and you really can't
do that I mean there's no way you won't
keep injuring your back if you keep
walking like that and how do you
re-pattern or help people to adopt so
that they can use it subconsciously new
motor patterns or new movement patterns
because I've been doing this for God
knows how many decades well not that
many you don't look that old
thank you thank you I appreciate that my
new best friend
how do you help patients to get to that
point where they've changed something as
fundamental as how they walk
in my mind it's twofold
in one we know it takes a while just
like if you're learning a sport or
you're learning to do anything it takes
time and it takes attention and it takes
specificity and so one is just like
we're talking about with you what are
the most important kinds of exercises
what what are the issues that are an
impediment to doing it the way you
should do it what are specific exercises
that can help you and minimize those and
then
what's really important is showing you
in your everyday activities
what you should do for example if you
already know that your hip flexors
you're calling it The iliacus
is problematic then even when you're
sitting making sure you're not pulling
with your hip flexors to stay forward
I'm probably doing that right now I know
I've been watching you
it's how you even roll over or get out
of bed
we go through every one of these things
teaching you in your everyday activities
so that it does become automatic but you
know it obviously takes participation on
the on the patients or the subjects part
as well
to learn it and then you know it's going
to take time
I think it's important for people to
realize they can't just do 10
repetitions or three sets of an exercise
and then they're going to move
differently I think that's been part of
what
been picked up in my in my book is that
you have to bring people along show them
how to do that and that exercise won't
change the way you move you have to
change the way you move and that can
improve how muscles function you
mentioned this so as I'd actually like
to come back to this OS in my particular
case because I have been an aggressive
athlete or was for several decades and
accrued an impressive number of
fractures and surgeries and so on I get
manual really oh yeah so I get manual
therapy once a week some type of soft
tissue treatment and what I found for me
personally is it seems like
like so as major and so on when someone
does a manual release for whatever
reason when they get sort of inside that
pelvis a bit more to what I've been told
is the iliacus that's when I feel the
most symptomatic relief for my back but
the psoas seems to hold some importance
I don't know if you could speak to that
but in terms of the role of psoas
overactivity as it relates to to back
pain
is that something that you still feel is
something people will pay too little
attention to
I don't think it's always the cause but
it can certainly be an exacerbator
because the psoas attaches to the lumbar
vertebrae and it also attaches to the
intervertebral discs so it's it's a
muscle that's constantly pulling on your
on your back and pulling it in sort of a
translation motion iliacus is attached
to your pelvis
so it's not directly acting on the
vertebrae the same way that the psoas is
in fact people that truly have a
herniated disc and they're in that acute
phase I try to have them do nothing with
their iliosaurus if they want to lift
their leg up use your hand to lift your
leg up
to put your shoes on or to
cross your legs or get into the car or
something if you're sitting down already
so you minimize that use and just like
we were talking about in quadruped if
you are in quadruped and you want to
rock back
you will probably use the psoas to do it
and that's why I suggested to you to
push with your hands so you go back and
you don't use that muscle well these are
small samples of what I'm talking about
as far as identifying what are the
factors that are contributing and how do
you change that in your everyday
activities
what would be some other
repeating culprits that you see let's
just say someone has the symptom of low
back pain you take them through an
assessment or identify that they have an
overactive psoas
what might be some other low-hanging
fruit with respect to helping them to
identify common patterns
or positions that contribute to that
overactivity I would be looking more
specifically at
which particular movements do it okay
and then try to identify
for example
it would be hard for me to believe this
but
if you're
hip flexors and and it makes a
difference like the tensor fasciae is a
hip flexor but it has a rotational
component that's much stronger than the
than the psoas does the psoas has more
anterior pull yeah the tensor fasciae is
going to pull more on the pelvis
and I will tell you that
in my judgment and I don't think I'm way
off on this at least 70 percent of the
people with back pain it's because their
hips not moving optimally and you said
it yourself my hip is not moving and
then it bothers my back well that's
exactly what goes on and it doesn't take
some big structural fault to have that
just a difference
in the passive tension so
usually with younger people if I'm going
to generalize about back pain
it's related to their spine flexing
because when you're younger you're more
you're more flexible
um
and I think the other thing that's tied
to that while we're talking about the
hip is they're identifying more and more
that hips what they call thermal
acetabular impingement hips aren't
flexing as much their structural changes
going on so if your hip only flexes 90
degrees then you want to bend over
you're going to do it much more in your
back because your hips not doing it so I
want to know all the things that relate
to flexion
in the older person
then it's more related to extension just
like the stenosis thing stenosis is
that's when you really can't extend
that's why you see old people walking
bent over why they need a walker when
they're bending over and then the
element of rotation
and because it's not just is it one
iliopsoas that's problematic or both of
them one tensor that's pulling more
strongly than the other
and that's the passive tension not just
the active tension and that's what you
have to know
now you were asking about my breathing
and the the deep breath when I when I
met with Eric and I I'm I could be
totally screwing up this terminology so
you may need to rain okay but he had me
take off my shirt and he's
I think it was I had a very low it might
be high but infrastinal angle so I have
a bit of a depression in the chest I
have a very minimal ability to
expand my rib cage I am a belly breather
and I've had a number of people note
that it's likely when I breathe I kind
of rotate my entire rib cage backwards
which also causes that excessive
symptoms exactly that excessive hinging
at the at the lumbar what do you do with
somebody who's got this type of
predicament or pattern
well usually as I was saying before
if your rib cage doesn't expand then
it's often because your abdominals are
too taut I see so one of the ways is to
elongate them so arms up over your head
and taking a deep breath
and just trying to increase the I mean
you probably know that with breathing
you've got two modes of movement one
they call Pump handle and the other is a
bucket handle I'd love for you to
elaborate on that okay well pump handle
means the front of your chest your
sternum is going up like a pump and
bucket handle is like the sides expand
mm-hmm
and so with arms up overhead you want to
really think about
lifting your chest as well as pushing
your rib cage out laterally you mean
yeah laterally like it's all going up
yeah can you do that can you take
yeah yeah it's sad yeah I don't have
much it doesn't do much no no as it
stands right now yeah that's what you
need to do and then here's the other
thing that if you stand with your back
against the wall and then you try to do
a side Bend but but
you want to make sure the side Bend
you're moving through that the axis of
rotations through your chest not in your
lumbar spine yeah that'll make my
symptoms worse and you want to be sure
Tim that you don't just pull yourself
over you want to try to fall like you've
got a heavy elbow
in other words don't contract the
muscles on the same side
but try to get these to elongate so
falling over more passive elongation
rather than an active contraction now
you're not going to go real far
initially unless you got a really heavy
elbow yeah
so the axis of rotation should be
through the middle of your the fulcrum
should be the middle of the chest yeah
right and don't I always like to say I
don't care how far you go I care how you
get there yeah okay so don't push it for
big range and just make sure you're not
moving your lumbar spine and that you're
doing your thoracic spine and are you
breathing in those positions or is this
stretching your intercostals or what is
the the objective of the the side bend
the objective is to elongate those
abdominals that are not letting you oh I
see and you know the the other thing is
just even when you were doing this
you don't have any symptoms at all when
you're sitting there right now I have a
little tightness in my low back I am
sitting in a chair with lumbar support
why do you do that when you have too
much lumbar curve anyway
well because I've I've noticed that for
whatever reason symptomatically I get
relief with a small amount of of lumbar
support no small amount okay if it's a
flat back chair and I end up kind of
falling forward and flattening my back
it it ends up hurting me much more later
yeah because you're getting a
translation motion yeah I could but okay
what if you put your arms up overhead
and take a deep breath does that
decrease your symptoms at all
I would say doesn't noticeably I don't
have any severe symptoms right this
instance no but but it doesn't doesn't
worsen it for sure but it doesn't make
it any better either
it might lessen it slightly okay
the degree of pan right now I would say
is pretty low so it's hard for me to
well that's good to Monitor and again if
you look at it from the standpoint the
more you move someplace else besides
your back
the better off you're going to be yeah
definitely so that's part of the whole
strategy is make sure because usually
the problem is that motion that's
problematic is occurring during all of
your activities the body follows the
rules of physics it takes the path of
least resistance so if it's easy to move
there it keeps moving there right and
that's what you're trying to change to
make it easier to move at other places
where you should be moving more this
seems to me to be very very very
important so would you mind just saying
that again
just reiterating
that the body follows the path of least
resistance so if you have a worn Groove
in its leading to pathology you need to
sort of grease a different Groove could
you could you just speak to that because
it's right you're doing a beautiful job
yourself I don't think you need me
well you know I'm great at pontificating
I just need to change my movements okay
father Superior
no I just you know I I talk a good game
I just have to fix my movement patterns
and my breathing but I like how you
phrase it I mean it's the body is going
to take the path of least resistance
that's it exactly
I'm going to follow these these
exercises I will I'll experiment with
the elongation I wanted to add
one more data point which is if I do for
instance
Pilates classes with someone who's very
technical if I'm in that flexed position
which tends to be more comfortable for
my back
if I'm experiencing a lot of tell me are
you supine
I am supine yes okay your Supine and
then what are you gonna do basically I'm
trying to sort out for myself is if
the overly contracted abdominal resting
state
can contribute to the symptoms of
experiencing what I have
what I have also experienced is if I do
a workout that seems to be focused or is
focused on a lot of core musculature and
pelvis work and so on that my low back
doesn't bother me for a few hours after
that workout and I don't know how to
interpret that maybe these things are
not at odds maybe they can both be true
for different reasons
I mean it depends on what your workout
is what what would be bad in the long
run is if you're doing a lot of holding
your legs up and moving those around
while you're supine because again you're
going to be using your iliopsoas and
it's going to be pulling on your back
yeah
the big thing is for you to be able to
contract I'm getting the picture from
you that I didn't have before that here
you are with an increased lumbar curve
and that your lower abdominals aren't as
taut in lower abdominals I mean external
obliques not just the ones that are are
lower
and when you contract those muscles that
they tend to flatten your back and
decrease your symptoms yes and so that
would be to me what the advantage is
when you're
supine is starting to do the exercise
what would be
not not the long run good is if you're
holding your legs up
and and trying to do something with your
legs while you're holding that position
right because you're building in too
much activity from the iliopsoas so if
anything in that position I would just
have you slide your leg down and try to
keep your pelvis from tilting put your
hands on your like I'm sure you probably
know what
Asis are anterior superior iliac spine I
do on the front of the hip yeah and just
make sure they don't tilt for people who
are wondering could you just describe
what that is it's a little bony
prominence on the front of your your
pelvis and some of your major hip
flexors attach there but it's also an
indication of what your pelvis is doing
as far as tilting forward or tilting
backward and in your case what you want
to do is not have it tilt forward so the
importance of that exercise would be
that you can move your legs without your
pelvis tilting anteriorly got it
but I wouldn't put a big load on them I
would only have them slide down
like you're sliding your heel along the
supporting surface got it get it all the
way down on one leg with no tilt see if
you can do the same thing with the other
if you have difficulty from what we've
talked about before if you take them out
in abduction you should be able to get
them down easier because your tensor is
going to be pulling on your pelvis as
well right so for people listening if
I'm interpreting this correctly if your
legs are separated so your legs end up
more in a snow angel type of position as
opposed to directly in front of your
hips now is that predominantly a
diagnostic or is it also a training move
that sliding of the heel all of the
above all the above okay I mean that's
the nice thing about going through an
exam in which you're looking for this
path of least resistance the motion that
is occurring too readily because it'll
occur too readily with all of the
activities and it goes back to what we
were saying before then you try to make
sure that you're either not getting that
motion or you're moving where you should
be moving
and when you're taking people through
the exam and I think this is what's so
valuable is you're also showing them how
to be in charge of their symptoms
because nothing is more scary then Here
Comes the Pain what did I do how did I
do it how do I get out of it and if
you're showing people if you go this way
it hurts if you do it this other way it
doesn't hurt
and and that's helps also with people
following the program that's recommended
because their symptoms are they're in
charge of them and they know what to do
to decrease them yeah this personal
experience has been incredibly
frustrating kind of horrifying because
it's the first time in my life if you
tear a labrum in your shoulder or you
break a break an arm or break a
collarbone it's oftentimes reasonably
straightforward or it seems that way
whereas with this lower back pain I
would feel better for three days and
then I would wake up and I would just be
in incredible like eight out of ten nine
out of 10 pain and I could not identify
what the cause was and there have been
times when you know my ql and my
external obliques and so on are so
locked up and the paraspinals that I can
stand for a few minutes and I have to
sit down find something soft and that's
not the case right now but the
recurrence of symptoms has been
so unpredictable on some level that it's
and a a friend of mine who's in the
medical profession said oh how long have
you had that and I said nine months and
she said well you're technically qualify
for someone with chronic pain and I was
like oh my God is this the new normal
this cannot be the new normal
which is why I appreciate you taking so
much time speaking about this
when someone comes in and they have not
identified anything they come to you for
help or someone who's trained in your
system
what does the exam
look like what does the what does the
session look like
first it's looking at what they look
like I mean yeah for me just like if I
saw you standing I would know a whole
lot more than just looking at you
sitting because all of these things that
we've talked about indirectly I would
see immediately so one is just looking
at alignment and believe me that's
that's a road map to a whole lot of
things and I think it's also worth
noting that it's why people stand the
way they stand is to minimize energy
expenditure so you can see what the
passive tensions are which are
reflective of how hypertrophy the muscle
is and then it's simple motions Tim have
people forward bend
does their back Flex too much does it
not reverse its curve with you and how
how much do their hips Flex
and typically in men there's more of a
problem of excessive lumbar flexion than
there aren't women just because the
center of gravity is higher the hips are
stiffer Etc so how do they forward Ben
how do they rotate because many people
will twist rather than really be able to
rotate
and then side bending does it hurt where
do I see the motion Now by twist you
mean their pelvis follows them instead
of that see that's the other thing
that's interesting is because
I'm sure with you that people have
looked at what your range of motion is
in your hips
but when you're standing you don't have
that same range of motion your pelvis
won't rotate on your femurs the same
amount yeah so one does your hips not
move and therefore you have to move in
your back more because your pelvis isn't
rotating or is it asymmetrical
and then the other thing is that
actually ironically if your abdominals
are really good instead of sort of
rotating off of more of an axis though
it's not perfect your trunk shifts over
because if your trunk shifts over in a
twisting motion it's because your
abdominals won't elongate easily hmm
fascinating and then which one of these
motions causes symptoms when I see that
it's bad I will correct it for example
if you had pain side bending then I'd
put my hand above your iliac crest have
you side Bend again and if I've blocked
it and you don't have pain then I know
that that motion occurring there is
causing your pain the movement of the
pelvis
or the Eli Crest the movement in your
back and the same thing if if you bend
over and there's no pain but you come
back up and you lead with your back
rather than your hips and that causes
pain then I know again that extending is
causing your symptoms
and then if your symptoms as you have
reported get better when you bend over
again I know that extension is causing
your symptoms
and then I go through little tests in
supine to see the length of the hip
flexor muscles
I look to see what your symptoms are in
supine
if you have symptoms
just like you sort of suggested if we
flex your hips and knees you want to be
more comfortable than when they're down
straight
if I abduct your hips I know that what's
causing it that way
you see what I mean so then I will
passively move your hips to see what the
range is
make sure it's passive then I'll have
you do it actively to see if that
elicits symptoms show you how to change
it so I'm going through an exam looking
for that movement that shows up
consistently if I stop it or improve it
the symptoms go down so we do in supine
sideline prone quadruped sitting
watch people walk
everything that gives them pain they get
in and out of their car how to roll how
to go up and down stairs
whatever activities would give them pain
and go through them with them
and is the assessment largely the same
for athletes versus non-athletes it's
kind of yeah that's a really interesting
point because
in some ways
people have a hard time because these
I'm looking for little baby things you
know ironically there's really good
research that's been done by by Linda
Van Dylan and
these movements that cause the symptoms
occur very early and they're only a few
degrees
and so sometimes with athletes I've had
the issue that well these are just baby
things and they don't really matter but
they do matter
you've got to stop that and then you can
build on on bigger ways there's a
therapist by the name of Robbie o'hashi
whose
put these into
it's like a movement Spectrum
that's not exact words I'm blanking on
right now where you do isolated
exercises combined exercises and then
more putting them together for your
sport you know whether it's tennis or or
whatever and he's seen a lot of athletes
and that's the whole idea is that you
get somebody to correct the little bitty
movements and then you build on the more
complicated the more demanding movements
do you have an opinion of I've
I've not experienced this personally but
something called DNS I think it's
Dynamic neuromuscular neuromuscular
system yeah I do because it seems like
they build based on some
sort of motor skilled development
chronology from childhood so you do
you'd start with supine or prone and
then move to like one to crawling or
something like that quadruped and then
kneeling and so on do you have any
perspective on this to be perfectly
honest I think you're already grown so
certainly if my if my shiny paint would
has any indication then yes you know
looking at your well-shaved head I I'm
always reminded of what my father used
to say who was also bald from an early
age and he would always say grass can't
grow on a busy Street
on a busy Street
oh
I don't think you need to Stage it like
that that's why I go through the the
whole exam and
look at the sort of the finished product
that needs some fine tuning you know the
the thing we talked about in the
beginning and that
movement causing pathology and the fact
that it's really your everyday
activities that cause it in the first
place yeah and so
that's why you gotta
change the way you're doing basic things
you know what I mean I do and look at
that because that's what caused the
problem that's what you need to change
what is I believe you call it collapso
smasho where did you get I didn't put
that down
well there are two Farms here it relates
to this fact that what we talked about
already that the abdominals can get
well that the spine suffers from
compression type things and in the older
individual without muscles it's collapso
smasho and younger individuals like
yourself or others who have done a whole
lot of abdominal exercises I call it
squeezo smasho because
because the passive tension from those
muscles is
adding to the compression in the older
people are people who are hyper mobile
then it's it's kind of collapsing down
without enough support so you know it's
not good if you don't have enough muscle
and it's not good if you have too much
muscle it's what's in between that's
most important
so how do you find the the Goldilocks
amount of no pain and they look great
all right keep fine tuning the other
thing is
you know obviously we we aren't all
built the same I think that's one of the
other important things is looking for
structural variations in building
building that into the assessment that's
the part that's tricky
um
people don't always pick the right
parents and when they find out it's too
late to go back you know
all right so let's talk about perhaps
other common
pathological patterns
I've read the the you've said or written
perhaps that most people wear their
shoulders too low
could you speak to that and perhaps also
mention what what corrective measures
can be taken
what does it mean for people to wear
their shoulders too low it means that
they should sit up at a an angle that is
about six degrees or so higher and often
you see when
you don't look so bad but when people
have done a lot of weight training
that's one end of this game you'll see
that their shoulders look really dropped
they look lower right so that the end of
their shoulder isn't sitting up they
look like they're sloped downward yeah
if you know the cervical vertebrae
between C6
and C7 you should have that's about the
level where your shoulders should be
and so if that's way down or you can
look at your clavicle and you see that
there's not this six degree angle but
your shoulder is slower than your than
your clavicle should from inside to
outside have roughly
angle upward angle right so it could be
too low
and then
the other way I like to talk about it is
just the weight of the world the husband
the children you know the bra straps all
of that pulling down and women's
shoulder girdles are just aren't as
stiff and and what what's important
about this is it's not only a factor of
what it does to your shoulders it also
does a number on your neck because the
muscles that help to hold your shoulder
blades up attach to your cervical
vertebrae
and the really big important thing on
trying to address that is using I think
the muscle that's called the serratus
anterior the serratus anterior attaches
to your rib cage and it can act like a
sling so attaches to your rib cage and
to your shoulder blades
so it's like a sling that can help to
hold your shoulder blades up and take
some of that load off of your cervical
spine as well as put your shoulders in
the right position and having your
shoulders sitting at the right position
is important for
the glenohumeral joint for all of the
shoulder joint motions to work without
subjecting them to Too Much injury
it seems like perhaps in weight training
I don't know if this contributes to the
the slope shoulders and maybe the flat
or downward angle of the clavicle but
the advice to depress and retract your
shoulders is common right for any number
of exercises and I recall meeting with
Eric and what he has a lot of his
athletes do and this is very individual
dependent so I'm not making a blanket
recommendation and I'm not speaking for
Eric but for instance as as he has
someone maybe retract on some type of of
standing pulling motion with say some
type of cable machine he'll have them
Reach forward
with the opposing side and it seems to
me that there's less of that kind of
fixed depressed and retract retracted
position in a lot of what he recommends
is working on these cerritus interior
doing exercises for the serratus
interior enough to correct that downward
slope to angle in people who have that
as a current state of affairs
number one is we have to be sure when
people have worked out now it depends
upon again what their workout routine is
if there's somebody that hangs and does
chin-ups one of the things can be the
latissimus Dorsey is this big muscle
and people do lab cooldowns Etc or they
do climbing things or hanging things and
that muscle will pull your shoulders
down so you got to make sure that that
muscle hasn't gotten too short and that
you can get your arms up over your head
in the first place
number two is
what you really want to do is use the
upper trapezius and the exercises where
you're down here is using
the rhomboids and the middle trapezius
and just for people who are listening
this is like a rowing motion yeah
anything where your arms are below your
shoulders are at the level of your
shoulders you're using muscles they pull
your shoulder blades together
but particularly the rhomboids
downwardly rotate
so it's going to make it more difficult
to get your
scapula to upwardly rotate and to get
the upper trapezius to work
so one of the things that is probably
more effective is actually
I like to start people off and I think
that's the other thing that when I look
at what recommendations there are on the
internet they never show people where to
start it's like do this exercise well
not everybody's ready to do that
exercise they've got to get ready to do
it right the way that's recommended but
if you can face the wall and slide your
arms up the wall
and then once your arms get to shoulder
to height
particularly when they're lower then you
shrug a little bit to get them up and
then you try to lift them off
while holding your shoulders up how far
are you standing from the wall oh you're
right up you're right up your face okay
got it right up there facing your elbows
are flexed you're sliding the little
finger side of your hands up there to
get it and then if you just let your
shoulders drop you've gained nothing
but you've got to also hold them up as
you lower your arms keeping your
shoulders up as you do this exercise
right keep them up get them up to where
they should be worn not closer to your
ears than your iliac crest
so you're looking to keep the shoulders
in that in the position where you want
to wear is angling up yeah slightly yeah
the other thing is it just makes such
common sense you can't spend the rest of
the day have them hanging down either
right so you should have a chair that
has armrests on it so that they're up
when you're you got your arm messed up
if you have to stand a lot you can put
them on your hips if one shoulder in
particular is problematic you can
support it with the other hand I mean so
again exercises will mean nothing if you
don't follow through if you're doing
even 20 minutes of exercise but you're
spending
12 hours with your shoulders hanging
down it ain't gonna work
what is your
position on and I know there are many
different types but stretching
this can be a controversial sometimes
polarizing topic
but can you elaborate on how various
forms of stretching should or shouldn't
be used in healthy and rehabilitating
populations
number one is really understanding what
you're meaning by by stretching one I've
talked about this as we've gone on
through this but
I keep using the term stiffness because
I feel like I was sort of misled during
my early days as a physical therapist
when I didn't
use my own
sense of looking carefully because we
were told that certain movements
occurred
because the muscle was too short and it
needed to be stretched I'll give you an
example
well the example we talked about already
if you're on your back and you slide
your legs down and your pelvis tilts
forward
your hip flexors are too short well
actually what it is is the struggle
between
the tension from your abdominals and the
tension from your hip flexors so
stretching your hip flexors is not going
to fix the lack of tension in your
abdominals
and so what I find is that most often
there aren't muscles that are short
there's a relative stiffness problem
so improving the stiffness of your
abdominals will elongate
your hip flexors
do you see what I mean yeah it's a
relationship not just an isolated muscle
that you need to stretch right and that
it isn't the length of the hip flexors
that's the problem it's the passive
tension from those those muscles
because when you're sliding your leg
down
that muscle isn't that active anyway
and if it's related to the length of the
muscle it shouldn't occur until you get
to the end of that muscle length right
and that's not when the tilting occurs
so there's all these things that just
don't make sense so what I found through
these numerous years of experience I've
had is that there's many more problems
with relative stiffness than there is
with muscles really being short now
if it's really short
then you also need to find out what's
making it short
because it doesn't just like oh I think
I'll go short today
right it's a matter of what is your
activity for example when I'm teaching
courses I have a great picture of a of a
young man who has
big curve like you're talking about an
increased lumbar curve clearly his hip
flexors are short and he's a cyclist
but you usually don't see that kind of
alignment in a cyclist you usually see a
flatter back but if I didn't let him use
toe Clips he couldn't move the petals
around so he moved the pedals by flexing
rather than pushing
so that's why his hip flexors were short
so it wouldn't matter how much you
stretched them if every time he went out
to ride the bicycle
he's using his hip flexors all over
again in a shortened position got it so
he's basically in that rear half of the
rotation of the pedal he's pulling with
his hip flexors right instead of more
pushing than just the the lifting so
what is it that people are doing
that's causing that muscle to get short
hmm
you know other examples and again I find
it so interesting about what intensive
weight training is doing because if
you're lifting I I've actually examined
young women who are lifting twice their
body weight well you know how many
muscles do you use if you were lifting
twice your body weight in a deadlift
like every little muscle you've got in
your body
well what happens is you end up training
all of those muscles to come on
and they don't just go off so they walk
stiff-legged because
there's too much activation of these
muscles and so they can't stand and have
muscles relaxed because everything comes
on it doesn't say I'll only come on when
I'm weight training you've trained them
to come on and now you've got much more
output for a given muscle
than you would otherwise so it's it's
too much so you've got to learn also how
to not activate them as much as you're
learning how to activate them I'm not
against any of this it's just that you
need to know what all the additional
factors are that take place with this
training so it's a long answer to the
question about stretching but my big
point is you've got to figure out what's
making it short then if you need
constant stretching
you've got a problem with what's active
what's making it short that has to be
addressed
so I've been advised and it seems to
help a bit but to do a fair amount of
say
hip bridging or glute activation
alternated with say hip flexor stretches
and if I have in addition to that the
stiffness in the abdominal muscles
contributing to this low back
presentation right these symptoms I'm
experiencing
could you just remind me of of how I
would then work on that abdominal
stiffness I could do I could do the
overhead breathing and the side that's
for that stiffness but again what you're
telling me and again I haven't seen you
standing but I could stand or else on
video okay would you like me to stand
please please
and I can tilt the camera as needed okay
yeah pull up the shirt so I can see
now turn sideways for me
oh
boy no no no I mean I don't know what
you're talking about your tummy is
sticking out
oh well yeah I mean like if I want to
look kind of in my second trimester I
can do that which one's the real you
this is probably the real this is the
real me this is this is how I would
stand if I were standing at an event I
would probably try to tuck my hips a bit
to take pressure off the back yeah but
you see you don't have an increased
lumbar curve you've got an increased
thoracic curve like the kyphosis on the
back yeah
yeah right up there and part of that
kyphosis comes from your rectus
abdominis pulling down on your thoracic
spine interesting right here yeah and
see when you lean back like that then
the rectus and the and the other
abdominals become your anti-gravity
muscles so they're constantly being used
meaning I lean back and then these are
pulling me forward yeah you lean back to
get away from those but you need to the
rectus needs to be a little bit longer
okay this needs to be a bit longer and
the best way for you to do that is to to
do the quadruped thing and then let your
thoracic spine go down so that would be
almost like the cat of the cat Cow I
guess sort of as I'm on my hands all you
need to do is think about letting your
chest go towards the floor and like you
feel the load on your shoulder blades
okay now let me watch you just easily
like you're going to contract your tummy
to pull it in
yeah you see you do sway back okay stop
you did Lean Back
that's it that's better that's better
now do you have any symptoms like that
at all
no there's a little bit of tightness
here but it actually
it doesn't bother me right now yeah okay
and it looks like your hips are fairly
straight so
go ahead and turn put your back to me
for a minute and put your hands on your
iliac crest
now with your hands like that they don't
look so bad to me
let's do what we talked about before put
your feet apart and let's just see what
happens if that changes your symptoms at
all
is it better
yes this would help
if I was a recording of a podcast what
would help even more is if I put my one
leg up on something
if I stepped on something
does it matter which leg
right leg right leg Yeah
it localized
right right yeah so that is going to be
the the tensor on that side now let me
do one more thing just bend over and
come back up
from the side like this yeah
well
yeah see now you need to work a bit on
how you come back up from forward
bending and don't worry about going over
that far
okay you need to come up with your hips
and less back as you finish off your
back you sway back and do too much back
extension oh when I get to the top
you're saying yeah about the last 30 40
so so hinge more at the hip
is that what you mean just think about
going over and coming back up by making
your hips extend okay
hold it there now hips just come back up
with hips hips hips hips hips yeah that
was better more like that
yeah and try not to let your back sway
back you you use the momentum of your
upper back coming back to finish up I
see I get a little you get a little
extension and that's not good over
extension right right right
anything else that I can yeah I mean I
can do more certainly this is helpful
if you can easily practice you've got
those
the lower abdominals or the external
obliques they're the ones that tilt your
pelvis and if you just easily practice
tightening those but don't work hard at
it so that you sway back
so this is the external obliques and
then what was the other muscular tree
you mentioned I'm saying don't sway back
just easily try to tighten them so you
get a little bit of a pelvic yeah plenty
now are you good that way
yeah I'm good yeah and this would be in
a standing position when I would have
just a little bit of tension in the
external if you do that as much as you
can
because you see it limitates your
symptoms that's all you need to do and
then work on that little increase
thoracic kyphosis
or I'm I guess reducing this kyphosis by
lengthening yeah if you decrease that
then you won't sway back so much I
and if your rectus abdominis elongates
better you won't have that tendency for
a thoracic kyphosis and to extend then
elongate the rectus abdominis for people
listening this is like six packs right
the stuff running down the front of the
abdominal I'm having a hard time hearing
you Tim oh sorry I forgot about the
microphone over here that
to elongate the rectus abdominis I could
get in that quadruped position right and
basically drop my chest to the floor as
I'm pushing my hips backwards just in
that position just let it go down
it's amazing how much you can improve
your alignment it looks like you you
could change pretty readily okay great
and the big thing so we started off
because you were doing that the bridging
exercise
I I wouldn't be tempted to do that
okay
one you'll do a much better loading of
your gluteal muscles by that bending
over and coming back up with your hip
extensors yep and if you tighten it
there there's also a tendency
for the glutes to actually
posteriorly tilt the pelvis but the
spine doesn't go along for the ride hmm
could you say more about that please
well it's kind of like this is one of my
guilt trips because
many years ago I was working
to get the point across I'll tell you my
little story yes please I was working
with this older woman I thought old was
my age now
and so she she did have spinal stenosis
and I was working on sit to stand so she
didn't have any symptoms
and I had her tried to tighten her
abdominals and she was doing pretty good
and then I said okay now let's tighten
your gluteal muscles as you get up
well she did that and she got pain
shooting down her legs and and the
reason being that
your gluteal muscles as you know
attached to the pelvis so if they
posteriorly tilt the pelvis but if the
spine doesn't want to go along for the
ride
it stays there and you get a translation
motion between where the pelvis is
moving and the vertebrae are not moving
right the gluteal muscles are basically
pulling the pelvis
right out from under the spine in a
sense exactly exactly not a good idea
now it's not your spine if your spine
moves easily then that's all right and
you can get the same effect if if you
would put your hand where your spine is
and tighten your glutes you'll see your
spine doesn't move did you see what I
mean
if it wants to go along for the ride
it'll go along for the ride but
the problem is those people where it
doesn't want to go along for the ride
and you're going to be one of them hmm
so in what ways do I need to be careful
then I mean I just don't think that's a
good a good exercise for you got the
bridging the bridging yeah yeah I feel
especially if if I do bridging
single leg but even even double legged I
remember it's been recommended to me by
a number of pts and I've told them all
like guys this really bothers my back
yeah yeah and it's arching your back
it's not a good plan yeah okay I'll skip
those I would skip those when do you
have time to do all this I don't I don't
that's honestly surely been one of the
compounding factors that has been so
frustrating is not only am I getting
very often entirely different
diagnoses but I also get 37 different
programs and there's just no way that I
can fit them in and many are probably
conflicting also right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and I found the movement
focused approach to make a lot of
at least intuitive sense to me if our
entire conscious experience of reality
is modeled on a brain that has evolved
to move us through space it just seems
to make sense that that is the variable
to pay a lot of attention to because
it's not just a variable but a system of
systems as you put it much like the
immune system so it makes a whole lot of
sense now you you just mentioned older
woman but she's now my age would hey
would you mind
sharing your age but also your own
self-care
I suppose routine what do you do to keep
as sharp and as in shape as as you are I
would I would love to know more about
that well yeah next month I'll be 86
years old it's incredible it's just
amazing I would never guess in a million
years I'm so lucky I'm so fortunate too
because
I don't mind saying both of my parents
had dementia I've now exceeded their
ages both in life and in dementia
right now I don't know that I have any I
would not think you have any
very very sharp so far so good so far so
good as I told you that number one
choosing to be a physical therapist and
also I was very fortunate because
growing up I refused to grow up and I
played Sports in in my day because when
are you going to grow up and stop all
that stuff and that was very good we
also didn't have air conditioning and we
only had one car so instead of paying
more for a bicycle than a car I had to
ride a big old bicycle and ride it
everywhere so I happily laid down enough
bone and enough muscle in my early years
and then the physician that I
encountered
who was part of the Department of
Medicine at Marshall University in St
Louis his name was John how is he
he started bringing in the lifestyle
issues
and as a physical therapist even though
I got a PhD in
neurobiology because I wanted to solve
the motor control problems of the stroke
patient
I stayed very Physically Active
I started really running and doing
things when I started my PhD studies and
after encountering this physician and
and learned a bit about nutrition
breaking all the family Tendencies
and then again learning about
musculoskeletal problems even though I
was really interested in working with
neurological patients people with spinal
cord injury head injury stroke
I had always had this tendency to look
at how people moved and
I totally tried to figure out why they
were moving the way they were moving Etc
and got involved with musculoskeletal
patients and they started getting better
so I had to figure that out and then I
applied my own ideas to to myself
in fact there I don't know how folks who
you want to get at but they're really
some funny stories connected with that
oh let's do it oh yeah no we love funny
stories around here and it really
related to
quadruped little exercise because
so one one sort of funny story was
I was really poor going through getting
my PhD because I didn't have any income
and was living off of a minimum amount
of money
and so I I didn't
get to buy new clothes very often
and I had a pair of slacks that I was
wearing for a long time and a friend
actually took me out to play golf and it
was an older woman at that time and
we're out playing golf and she says you
know surely you've got your pants on
backwards and I said you know I'm
working on my PhD I think I ought to be
able to know how to put my pants on
and so we started looking at the darts
and sure enough I had them on backwards
well before
before my alignment was such that they
looked all right but now that I was
doing this quadruped exercise
they didn't look all right they were
looking funny because I had changed the
Curves in my back and my buttocks and so
that's why she caught the idea that I
wasn't wearing my pants right
which quadruped movements were these
it's just the idea of being in quadruped
and just letting your back go down and
then rocking back
mm-hmm
I tended to sit ride the bicycle I was a
a catcher for three different softball
teams so I was really in a posterior
tilt with a really flat back got it and
I had never really
gone the other way
and just for people who are listening if
you don't know I just do it to imagine
if you imagine that the sort of the the
pelvis as a bowl of soup posterior tilt
you're kind of pouring soup out the back
of your Elvis just holding it in the
middle yeah yeah right yeah got it okay
so your back your whole back goes kind
of flat then and when you're pushing
your hips back you're facilitating more
of a natural curve in the lower back you
know I was you know getting my hips to
bend and yeah letting my back go down so
it's getting more of a curve and I think
also decreasing a bit of a Tennessee
towards a thoracic hyphosis
the other thing that was really an
interesting I I used to bowl you know
like with a bowling ball and while I was
in my PhD program which took me six
years
I didn't have any money to bowl and so
when I went and got my bowling ball out
again I had to change the finger grips
because I had stretched my finger
flexors out and so the finger grips no
longer fit me because my fingers were
were longer can you explain that see
your your grips had been molded to
fingers that were well my fingers were
always flexed from everything I did
right and I never really thought about
stretching them out and so when you're
in quadruped
you end up stretching those all out
right okay I see right instead of so for
people who are listening because we're
making movements with their hands and
gestures with their hands oh you can't
see we're gonna make the video available
as well but some people will only hear
audio so instead of being sort of that
keyboard
it's you know Hawk Talon position when
you're in quadruped right as if you were
doing a push-up but not that push-up
position if your hands are flat on the
floor then you're going to be stretching
those flexors stretching across the
wrist and across the fingers yeah got it
so you had to change your bowling ball
that's wild yeah and then the other
thing is I had always worn my shoes off
so that they were going off to the side
and
after I did this you know few years of
this quadruped rocking I didn't walk in
the same way and I didn't have my shoes
weren't worn off to the side from just
walking oh interesting so worn off to
the side you mean the shoes on the
inside were worn or on the yeah like the
outside of the right and the inside or
the left so there were all these little
changes that took place just from
improving my alignment partly with that
so to go on to answer your full question
so what do I do these days
guess what I still do quadruped I don't
go all the way back and sit on my heels
and I also want to tell you about one
thing people need to know about that
exercise
and then
I do a modified
push-ups modified push-ups in prone and
I think that if you could do this
carefully it'd be good
is
in prone I I flex my knee so that my leg
as much as possible is falling
falling on my thigh
so is this similar to what you're
describing
you're laying down on your chest yeah
I'm laying down face down bend my knee
and I tried to get my leg
to fall back on my thigh because I don't
want to hold it bent at 90.
in other words if you Flex if you bend
your knee you can go to 90 degrees if
you go more than 90 degrees your leg is
falling on your thigh I see right your
lower leg is sort of falling under your
hamstring yes that's your thigh yeah got
it okay
in that position
then I lift my thigh off of the floor I
do hip extension but not high there's
only 10 degrees of motion but it's a way
to stretch it's a way to use your
gluteal muscle because you can't if you
use your hamstring you'll get a cramp
yeah you'll get a bad cramp in your
hamstring
so just a little bit of hip extension to
use my gluteal muscle how many
repetitions are you doing on each side
or what is I just do 10 repetitions on
one side and then 10 repetitions on the
other and you're doing roughly 10
repetitions of the quadruped rocking as
well yep I'm not sure if that's original
15 push-ups 15 modified push-ups
modified is your Naser vent I don't go
to my toes got it okay
and then still in the prone position
knees flexed to 90 degrees and then I do
hip rotation
you know in both directions letting my
lower leg come in and then go out
come in and go out right so just if I
can translate and please
correct me if I'm getting this wrong but
you're bending one you're laying on your
on your chest one leg bent to 90 degrees
and basically windshield wiper with that
lower leg on each side yeah but I do
both at the same time oh you do both at
the same time okay yeah so they're not
quite you know ones maybe 80 the other
Maybe 70.
just
because it doesn't take all that long
yeah right and then with my knees
extended straight with my lower
extremity straight
I alternate doing hip extension but I
think about using my gluteal muscle
I think about activating my gluteus
maximus
and again only about 10 degrees of hip
extension okay
and then in that same position I do hip
abduction in other words
one leg out to the side ten times
because you use you use your gluteus
medius and that better if you're working
against gravity and extension than you
do when you're supine okay supine you
tend to recruit the tensor too much oh I
see
um
got it
and
is there anything that that follows that
abductor work
then I go supine I turn over and I think
this is really
you know
I'm pretty good about not having a
kyphosis but
I have to a deduct in supine I a deduct
pull my shoulder blades together and
slide my arms up over my head
so that my arms are all the way up over
my head as much as I can and I'm on a
hard floor
and I'm starting with my hips and knees
bent arms up overhead and then slide one
leg down slide the other leg down and
believe me for an older person who's got
a tendency towards collapso smasho
just getting yourself as stretched out
as possible is so important
um yeah I mean really sounds like for me
with my kyphosis that would also be
important yeah the biggest worry is
going to be with the older person
that if you have a kyphosis you're not
going to be able to get your arms on the
floor all the way up over your head
you know when any pain on top of your
shoulder because that's not going to be
a good plan so they may need to have a
pillow up there
when they're first starting
to
so their arms don't go all the way back
because you want to avoid any kind of
pain on top of your shoulder but happily
I know how to do it and I can do it and
then I do active actively hip and knee
Flex you know bring one knee towards my
chest put it down and the other one
and 10 times with each leg
and then with one foot on the floor I do
a straight leg raise but I don't like
tighten all my leg my thigh muscles so
that my knee is perfectly straight and I
turn it out a little bit so that I don't
use
the tensor
I'm gonna but if I rotate it out you'll
use the psoas more and I think about
tightening my abdominals
okay
because I have had a significant problem
and I I don't want to put too much
stress on my lumbar spine from the
iliopsoas I want to use it but I want to
protect my back that's why I have one
foot on the floor I see that's why
you're doing one leg at a time well yeah
it's certainly one leg at a time so
could you just reiterate given the last
lumbar issue why you would want to
engage the psoas instead of the tfl in
this case
it's a good muscle to use I need to be
able to flex my hip but the tensor
it has a real low threshold for
Activation I mean interestingly enough I
see if you would scratch the bottom of
your foot the first muscle to go off
will be your tensor fasciae no kidding
yeah in fact I think it's so interesting
because
I've tried to contact the World Health
Organization because all over the world
the tensor is run amok but they listen
to me they're not returning the calls no
I know and it's this little bitty wimpy
muscle and you say how can it cause so
much trouble but it sure does you know
it plays a role in what happens to the
knee and plays a role in what happens to
the back and the hip I mean
it's an evil thing but
well anyway you know an interesting
thing one of my colleagues was doing a
study and we actually had a student that
did not have a tensor fasciae
no kidding yeah we didn't throw out a
school or anything but
but anyway I couldn't wait to do all the
tests that we do to look for the length
of the tensor and she was a you know a
fair athlete
so it wasn't like it had been sitting
not doing anything if it was there and I
did all the tests and they were negative
which was kind of supportive to me that
indeed the tensor does do things that
aren't so kind to the rest of the body
so anyway all that to say that's why
when I do the straight leg raise I try
to laterally rotate my hip because I'd
rather use the psoas
and then I would the tfl and it's not
causing me any problems clearly if I
thought I was injuring myself I would
not would not do that and then I do one
other thing with one leg straight and
the other foot on the floor
so that my knee is bent my foot's on the
floor I let my leg go out to the side
and that's my way of trying to work on
controlling rotation with the trunk my
leg goes out to the side it wants to
rotate your pelvis but Contracting your
abdominals prevents that rotation so
that's another way I'm trying to work my
abdominals and then
and then I stand up and you know I'm so
proud of myself because
I can get up from the floor without any
difficulty and
and many people at my age are many years
younger than that can't do that
um
and put my back to the wall and then do
what I was telling you to do arms up
overhead and do
do the little side Bend thing
and you do this every day I do and then
I walk three to four miles a day
amazing
sometimes ride a stationary bike
well these are things I'm paying more
and more attention to I'm so impressed
but let me tell you one thing now Tim
that the quadruped as much as I love it
and I think it's important whether you
have a shoulder problem a cervical
problem
Etc is
that one of the things that's a problem
though and it can be for several reasons
but again the tensor is one of them if
you rock back and your hip immediately
rotates
in other words I found this in some
patients that
as you rock back your hips should just
flex but if you are monitoring the femur
you can sometimes see that it
immediately rotates
right that is really bad and the reason
why it's really bad is because it's
rotating in your knee joint too and
that's a good way to set yourself up for
an ACL tear anterior cruciate ligament
ooh yeah yeah yeah yeah and I think
people should be monitoring that anybody
that's doing that
one of the things that helps is if you
slightly laterally rotate your hips you
know many people particularly men come
with what we call femoral retroversion
do you know what that is
I don't okay well you probably have it
ephemeral retroversion it's a structural
variation and so the femur
as you know has
a head and neck on it it's angled well
it's also rotated on the shaft
right and if it's in the ideal world the
average not the normal the average is
that that rotation is 15 degrees
so the head and neck of the femur are
pointing 15 degrees forward
now many men it's not rotated so what it
means is that when you're doing your hip
rotation you go out a long ways but you
don't go in
that's true for me for sure yeah my
internal rotation is terrible compared
to my external rotation but that's
because you came that way and it should
never change no I mean it and so yeah
and men need to know that and so in fact
that's a problem because if your tensor
is really developed you could be sitting
in Hip medial rotation when you
shouldn't be
and if your glutes are really good
that'll also immediately rotate your hip
when you're sitting that's a problem
okay
yeah okay so one of the ways to if
you're trying to do the quadruped thing
is to turn your hip out a little bit
when you're in the quadruped position so
your feet would come together a little
bit closer right more of like a
wrestling part-tier position yeah I
don't know I never wrestled oh yeah yeah
I could I can pick up the slack on
explaining that then so not with a
referee anyway
okay anyway right right so from the feet
to the knees it would just be making a
very very very slight v-shape it's not a
V shape but the the lines would converge
in other words right your feet would be
a little bit closer together exactly
um huh
funny
all right so that makes a lot of sense
to me and I'm certainly comfortable with
that what what would it mean or how
would you read the movement pattern that
I have of sitting and having my legs
sort of splay open that's also something
really good that alleviates my low back
symptoms if I'm sitting in a chair
oftentimes I'll take my shoes off and
fold them up on top of the chair
restaurants hate this by the way
so I do get chastised occasionally but
but it alleviates some of my lower back
issues yeah you're getting it four and
aft because
you're probably in this this is one of
the syndromes I have of the hip that
I've described to the hip because if
your tensor is really develop it's going
to be holding your femur in medial
rotation when you're standing because
it's pulled taut then if your gluteals
are really well developed
when your hips flexed to 90 degrees they
become medial rotators too so they're
trying to hold your hip and medial
rotation and you're probably getting
that Twist on your back then do you see
what I mean yeah so when you laterally
rotate your hips
then you're taking that pull off of them
taking the pressure off of it yeah yeah
you're not getting that extra pull on
your pelvis from those gluteal muscles
being pulled so taut and that's where
you should be that's your your normal
thing because you have femoral
retroversion
see that's one of the things that's bad
is because you know like when people go
in and they're not dead lifts and they
say well make your feet Point Straight
Ahead well
many men in particular shouldn't have
their feet pointing straight ahead
because they have this femoral retro
version
and also when they do things that rotate
like play golf their feet should be
turned out because if they're Straight
Ahead they're in at the end of their
medial rotation range yeah do you see
what I mean so then it'll be the knee or
the back or the hip so they're going to
go
um
makes a lot of sense yeah it's also
interesting
yeah super fascinating yeah it's like
the backbones attached to the pelvic
bone you know and I think to me that's
what's so valuable about
being a physical therapist or looking at
people because I can't like an
orthopedic surgeon just look at the knee
or I can't just look at the hip because
it's the result of all of these
interactions of the body that's what's
so important
and in a case like mine where if you
look at family photos right especially
on my mom's side the feet Point way out
I mean a lot of the guys stand like
ducks now at the same time
I've been told and I agree with this
that if if one were to watch me walk I
have probably because I have at times
the feet pointing out
very little sort of glute hamstring
assisted hip extensions so I tend to
bend at that lower back maybe a
misdiagnosing things but
how would you sort of make sense of that
would it be bad for me to try to point
my feet a little more straight ahead so
that I get better hip extension using
the gluteal muscles and the hamstrings
versus the lower back or is that going
to be setting me up for knee problems
usually if you're not using your gluteal
muscles in that it's because you're
you're swayed back
[Music]
if you swayed back your line of gravity
is behind your hip joint right and if
your line of gravity is behind your hip
joint you don't need your gluteals
those other muscles so if if you reduce
that kyphosis and get rid of the which
isn't bad it's just not helpful for what
your condition is yeah
and then you go forward and then the
other thing is
if you also push off in other words when
you're walking
mm-hmm
and this could be another way in which
you're reinforcing what your tensor is
doing if you tend to walk by pulling
your leg through rather than pushing
with your feet and letting it swing
through right and if you push with your
feet you'll activate the extensors more
so the two things the things that may be
contributing to you and I'm not saying
this is for sure because I'm obviously
not
analyzing you but let's say if we paint
a scenario that you're swayed back with
a kyphosis your line of gravity is
behind your hip joint I always call it
then the gluteals are do not have good
definition I call it missing for lack of
action
and so then then you pull your legs
forward with your hip flexors you're
just reinforcing the overuse of the of
the tensor but if you decrease your
kyphosis so your line of gravity is a
little more
running through your hip rather than way
behind it and you roll over your feet
and you push with your feet
do you know what I'm saying I do so you
roll over so that you're pushing with
the ball of your foot and your leg
swings out you'll use your gluteals more
yeah makes perfect sense just pushing
instead of pulling
you want to chase your center of gravity
not pull it yeah this kyphosis has been
been with me since I was a little kid
and it's it's I've tried foam rolling
manual release strengthening the mid
back and but I have not worked on
elongating the rectus abdominis you know
there's a condition called Sherman's
disease which isn't really a disease but
it it if you had it particularly it
happens in your teenage years where you
get a you've heard of it no I haven't
heard of Sherman's disease but I ever
since I would say since I've been like
12 13 I've had this kyphosis lordosis
combo well then you probably got
Sherman's disease
huh okay I'll have to look it up it's
s-c-h-e-u-e-r-m-a-n-n okay and it's kind
of a idiopathic compression fracture of
the thoracic spine it means you won't
get rid of it oh man okay well but I
think if you if you just don't sway back
more
you know what I mean uh-huh and just
stay forward a little bit if you can
make peace with that well I can try to
work on the elongating of these well
it's not going to change
the big thing is don't let it get worse
right if that's what you have I'm not
saying that's what you have but I'm
saying right it's possible yeah because
it happens around the teenage years
um so what would be the keys to not
letting it get worse would you say
don't have an increase I mean you can
still do the same things Tim but yeah
just don't say
I will be absolutely perfect I have to
settle for Kind of Perfect instead of
absolute perfect yeah that's probably a
good ammo for most of my life I would
say
all right well most of us don't get that
close I think there we go
I'm probably further away than I would
like to admit so surely this has been
such a great conversation we've covered
so much I've taken copious copious notes
and certainly people can find your books
the diagnosis and treatment of movement
impairment syndromes which has been
translated into seven languages as well
as your second book movement system
impairment syndromes of extremities
cervical and thoracic spines has been
very influential in promoting movement
diagnoses is there anything else you
would like to mention anything else we
should talk about anything you would
like to draw attention to with my
audience anything at all that you think
is is worth saying or discussing before
we begin to wind to a close well it's
probably just a little repeat of all the
things we've been talking about it it's
been really great and generous of you to
allow me to discuss your your issues but
you know what's really nice is here you
are somebody that's worked so hard to
address all of these things with all the
discipline that most people don't have
and and it's still hard to get a
straightforward story about what's going
on and how best to suture and that's
what worries me a lot is number one is I
look on the internet for exercises and
and most of them people can't do and
they're not taking into account the
variations in how people are I mean here
you've been through all this exam and
nobody said you have femoral
retroversion which right you need to
know because you came that way you need
to stay that way
mm-hmm so I would like to see that
there's more
respect for how difficult
exercise is it's not like
here's the way everybody should go out
and do this one thing and then they'll
all will be well I'd like to see this
recognition of that movement is is
complicated as anything else that the
body does
that there is a movement system a
physiological thing
and that we should have diagnostic
categories so that people when they're
Consulting a physical therapist get a
diagnosis just like when they go to any
doctor I mean that's to me why you go to
a doctor is to get a diagnosis or find
out what condition you're you're working
on
and I think that would do a lot to help
reducing all this variability in
in treatment
and I think helping people to understand
how it's the way they do their everyday
activities that causes the problem and
that those can be changed with with good
direction
you know what I can't help but say this
too
I I help a good friend who's actually on
a dementia floor I go to
help feed her twice a day and I look at
all the other people older people that
are in assisted living and the majority
of them are there because they have
physical disabilities
hmm I'm older than most of them
yeah and I think if people had a chance
to to address these things early on and
with the discipline like you show and
good direction we could cut down on and
improve the quality of life
I know you've interviewed a doctorate
and
you know much of what he says you know
medicine 3.0 or something and if we did
that with more Care on exercise
and knowing how to do everyday
activities and not just take them for
granted I think people could have longer
Fuller lives
and
be as fortunate as I am
grid agreed agreed
what a great conversation I've I've
learned so much and I've taken so many
notes I have a lot to dig into it's also
given me some renewed optimism in terms
of
exercises that I can work with movements
I should say that I can experiment with
I hope you'll get back to me if I can
help further I will if you find out that
these things are going along I would be
more than happy to
thank you do this a little more formally
yeah I absolutely I really appreciate it
you can do it I mean we can do it on
this yeah that I would I would very much
like to do that so thank you for the
very kind offer and thank you for
so kindly taking the time to have this
conversation I think it'll be really
helpful to people as my dear friend
Michael said you are tremendous I've
really enjoyed talking to you and you do
have a sense of enthusiasm and how to
ask the right questions to make it fun
for both of us
thank you so much and for everybody
listening we will link in the show notes
to everything we discussed as usual at
tim.blog podcast and until next time be
just a bit Kinder than is necessary not
only to others also to yourself and as
always thanks for tuning in